welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us at today's seminar accurate
clinical concentration response
predictions for cardiac arrhythmia using
a population-based in vitro in silico
model presented by dr. Wei shreya Shu
professor at the veterinary integrative
Biosciences at the College of Veterinary
Medicine and biomedical sciences at
Texas A&M University my name is Susie
Valdez and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during our
presentation simply click the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
meditation and follow the process to
obtain your credits without further ado
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. chu I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thank you very much Susie for that kind
introduction I'm very happy today to
present this webinar about how we're
using an in silico in vitro model to
predict concentration response
relationships for cardiac arrhythmias
I'm giving this presentation on behalf
of the Texas A&M North Carolina State
University
EPA star center I will begin with the
acknowledgments this Center is a multi
institution collaboration from Texas A&M
in North Carolina State University with
additional collaborations with molecular
devices the National Toxicology program
ICF international seller dynamics and
protein fluidics and the funding sources
are listed over on the right the
learning objectives today are first to
describe some of the current practices
in cardiotoxicity assessment for
xenobiotics and then to explain how
induced pluripotent stem cell derived
cardiomyocytes may be useful in
advancing the assessment of cardio
toxicity for xenobiotics so first by
giving a brief background as to the
cardio toxicity of siemens antibiotics
and how they're assessed then I'll
describe an in vitro and silica model
that we have developed as part of our
Center to make clinically relevant
predictions for an arrhythmia called QT
prolongation and then I'll end with some
implications and future directions for
this research so cardiac toxicity is a
known hazard for pharmaceuticals a large
fraction of drugs that have been pulled
off the market or that never make it to
market are are due to a cardio toxic
events and in fact for post-approval
adverse event reports cardiac
arrhythmias are the leading number of
those types of events so the question
then based on their experience with
pharmaceuticals is whether this also
might apply to say environmental and
industrial chemicals so for air
pollution this is known to be an issue
as well both for cardiovascular disease
as well as other types of biomarkers
like QT interval they appear to be
affected adversely by air pollution
other exposures the question is more
open there's little data beyond some
epidemiologic studies on a few chemicals
that are very well studied in addition
to air pollution led environmental
tobacco smoke are other examples in
arsenic but because it's not routinely
tested in experimental animal
study is now getting to that in a little
bit in a few slides this really an open
question as to the broad swath of the
you know tens of thousands of chemicals
that are in commerce whether they might
induce cardio toxicity in humans in our
work we are using QT interval as a
biomarker of cardiovascular risk this is
because it is a well-established
biomarker for both genetic and
drug-induced cardiotoxicity and is known
to increase the risk of sudden cardiac
death for congenital QT prolongation
those individuals once they're
identified are you know prescribed from
suitable in order to blunt that their
heart rate so this is to prevent
breathing this from resulting from the
QT prolongation and drug-induced QT
prolongation is a major issue for furn
since can't chemo therapeutic drugs
because you know those individuals can't
avoid using those drugs but the adverse
effects of cardio toxicity can be an
issue during treatment in addition
there's an emerging literature over the
last three to five years that even
baseline QT interval is a risk factor
than in the general population in a
number of observational studies have
associated QT interval in the normal
range with increased incidence of
cardiac death major cardiovascular
events or death and other effects such
as stroke in atrial fibrillation the
molecular and physiological basis of
these risks is thought to be as follows
and is shown on the right side here with
the QT prolongation being prolonged this
is due to a delayed action potential in
the heart this delayed action potential
then leads to an increased likelihood of
arrhythmias a particularly one card for
solid to plant and this arrhythmia then
can this very severe arrhythmia can then
increase the likelihood in my
cardio infarctions which then of course
increase the likelihood of death and so
that it's presumed then that in the
population if there is an increase in
the QT interval across a population that
will then increase the incidence of
adverse cardiovascular events in the
general population because of these
concerns the first you know drugs are
now routinely tested for potential
cardiac cardiotoxicity during early drug
development is a combination of in vitro
and in vivo assays which provide
evidence or lack of evidence of cardio
toxic risks but in late drug development
in during you know phase one and onwards
but even if there are no preclinical
concerns there is still the requirement
for what's called a thorough QT study
that tqt study and this is a
multi-million dollar clinical trial that
intensively measures the QT interval by
EKGs in in volunteers that are exposed
that are administering these drugs I
should emphasize that the reason why
this trial is required even without
preclinical concerns is that the those
assays and early drug development are
not always sensitive enough to detect
potential concerns once it goes in vivo
now the threshold of regulars are
concerned that FDA and the International
regulatory bodies have established is
that the upper 95% confidence bound for
the change in the QT interval cannot be
more than 10 milliseconds and since this
has been implemented in the last 10 or
15 years this has been highly successful
in reducing cardio toxicity and approved
drugs on the other hand for other types
of xenobiotics there really is no safety
testing strategy for cardio toxicity
even for compounds that are intensely
tested in pre clinic
in preclinical models such as pesticides
there is no general approach
to addressing this this effect and some
of the reasons are shown here first is
they're the rodents that are typically
used even in those in vivo studies are
fed low fat diets and are not monitored
for arrhythmias and cardio toxicity
beyond you know gross pathology or
histopathology and effects on rhythmic
effects do not often show up in
pathological examinations second the
Marine preclinical models that do seem
to be some a predictive of cardio
toxicity such as dog models are not
routinely used for non pharmaceuticals
because they are more expensive and it
you know they have a smaller and that
you can afford for in conducting those
proposed safety tests that ends up
meaning that the cardiovascular effects
of chemicals in the environment and in
industry is mostly based on
epidemiologic data which means that it's
not really safety testing this is
assessing effects that are already
occurring in the population so some of
the limitations of the current
approaches are first the drug test in
the drug testing world the preclinical
models and even the thorough QT study is
not to have high sensitivity but there
are some questions raised as to these
specificity they're also high cost
whether it's dog studies or the clinical
trials they are much higher cost than
preclinical studies third there's the
issue of population variability even the
regulatory threshold by FDA is a mean
effect and doesn't necessarily
characterize susceptible subpopulations
and then for you can't conduct clinical
trials on non pharmaceuticals because of
ethical concerns the FDA of course is
aware of this and in collaboration with
industry is addressing some of these
issues particularly the first to through
its SEPA initiative the comprehensive in
in vitro Pro Ric Pro a rhythmic essay
initiative our Center at Texas A&M in
North Carolina State University
is addressing these other challenges and
also in the context of non
pharmaceuticals the basis of a large
part of our work is to take advantage of
the potential for induced pluripotent
stem cell derived cardiomyocytes these
are fairly low costs especially compared
to clinical trials they're actually
commercially available through companies
such as cellular dynamics which is the
Fuji company there is the potential in
addition for population level in patient
specific screening there is it's not
just one cardio myocyte line that has
that is available but there's multiple
lines derived from multiple individuals
and there's been an interest in the
precision medicine world of using
patient specific induced pluripotent
stem cell derived cardiomyocytes to do
precision medicine now these cells once
they have been coaxed into becoming
cardiomyocytes beat synchronous
synchronously in vitro and they exhibit
a lot of the types of responses that are
expected from congenital as well as
driving drug-induced cardio toxicity and
because they are derived from induced
pluripotent stem cells and they are also
commercially available these are
reproducible resource and unlike primary
cells which you know are different each
time so about a year and a half ago we
published a proof of principle in which
we looked at drugs
pesticides and some other industrial
chemicals in a cardio myocyte
of model and we found that indeed first
as expected from other you know previous
literature drugs that are known to cause
QT prolongation say will prolonged QT or
they analogous the analogous rhythmic
pattern in vitro in this system when the
nisshin has found that a number of
pesticides as well as pah is politically
aromatic hydrocarbons also seem to
affect cardiac rhythm
there's increasing or decreasing the
beat rate or change or inducing
something analogous to rhythm is like QT
prolongation so this seems to suggest
that indeed cardiotoxicity
hazard might exist in environmental
chemicals given that these are known to
work for congenital and for drug-induced
adverse effects and it appears that that
some environmental chemicals are also
causing these effects so we wanted to
take this further from you know not only
demonstrating that it can occur but
trying to actually quantify the
concentration response relationship so
that you know regulatory decision making
can be made on this end point for
xenobiotics that are not pharmaceuticals
so our central hypothesis is that a
population based in vitro model combined
with his in silicon pharma-quick in
dynamic modeling can lead to an accurate
prediction of in vivo results equivalent
to an in vivo clinical thorough QT study
so in this study even though our
ultimate gain our ultimate goal is to
address environmental chemicals we're
focusing here on on drugs for which
there is clinical thorough QT type data
so we're trying to predict first the
concentration response of relationship
in terms of the actual change in QT as a
function of concentration and then
second whether we can actually quantify
the range of concentrations that would
satisfy a particular regular regulatory
threshold such as that for hours for
drugs that are promoted by FDA so with
that I'll go into now some you know what
our model is and how we developed it as
well as the results so our study design
we took induced pluripotent stem cells
that were available for 27 different
individuals and then we looked at its
effects
on 13 different drugs 10 that were
positive for in vivo QT prolongation and
3 that were known to be negative and and
have been thoroughly tested in clinical
trials for QT prolongation so then we
have you know this is examples of
different beat patterns for the top row
is at controls for just-just-just DMSO
and then and media and for three
different representative donors and as
the concentration increases going down
you have no changes in the B pattern and
at higher concentrations you see that
characteristic arrhythmia in which the
beat doesn't fully decline to two
baseline and plateaus for some time
before going down to baseline and that
is sort of the in in vitro equivalent to
a QT prolongation so these beat patterns
were then quantified using a peep
processing algorithm then we use
Bayesian population modeling to model
the concentration response relationship
and then as well we use rapid
equilibrium dialysis to relate the
concentrations in our assays to
concentrations in vivo in order to have
a full prediction as to the invivo
concentration response relationship for
QT prolongation and then those were then
compared with literature concentration
response results so just a little bit
more detail about how this comparison
between in vivo and in vitro works so
qualitatively on the in vivo side here
there's a normal EKG and then the QT
prolongation is the interval from the Q
wave to the T wave and how that
increases with increasing concentration
and then with tor saw you get this very
irregular very rapid beating pattern
before we get to questions when the
heart is no longer able to be now in
vitro you have normal beating which
doesn't have this the same amount of of
sort of detailed wave patterns as the
EKG does but when you get to QT
prolongation you get this characteristic
knotch formation in which the the the
peak rises at a normal rate but then
decay then there's a delay and how it's
able to decay down to baseline and then
at higher concentrations you get the
very rapid small beating analogous to
toursad to plant and then eventually it
gets to quietens at higher cuts and even
higher concentrations so quantitatively
we used published pharmacodynamic
modeling results for concentration
response relationships for QT as sort of
our gold standard and then we modelled
the change in this decay rise ratio as a
function of concentration from our in
vitro system and then we simply compared
them so this comparison then requires a
number of different conversions or
common commonalities first is what is
the dose and what is the dose of
equivalence and so here we presume that
the free concentration that is the
concentration that's not bound to
protein should be the same you know when
compared across in vivo to in vitro so
for in vivo we use literature based
values for what the free fraction in
serum was to scale the total
concentration from literature to free
concentration and then in vitro we
actually measured using rapid
equilibrium dialysis what the pre
fraction in serum and courteous myocyte
media was to convert those
concentrations that were measured in
vitro or applied in vitro to to a common
metric and then the other question is
what is the common effect metric so the
beading of in vitro cardiomyocytes is
somewhat slower than typical you know
normal in vivo heart rates because the
heart though there's no pacing these are
just spontaneous this is the spontaneous
be rate of the cardiomyocytes
so we based on you know other cows
illogical principles we posited that if
you change both of these to a percent
change so a five percent change in QT
prolongation from baseline and a five
percent change in the decay rise ratio
from baseline then this would produce a
common effect metric that that you could
then compare given that the baseline
rates are so different between in vivo
and in vitro and then of course we only
restricted the comparisons to the c-max
that's achieved in vivo since that's the
range over which there's actually in
vivo date so in terms of clinical
translation we then took these
concentration response relationships and
then use baseline QT level of Duty
values in the relevant in vivo
population then converted the
concentrations back to plasma
concentrations and then predicted that
plasma concentration of each compound
that would be predicted to have higher
or lower than a ten millisecond change
in QT and that then is our sort of
thorough qt study in a dish where we
basically are modeling an entire
clinical trial in an in vitro system so
that what's that what are the results so
this is a an example with dye so
pyramide of the concentration response
relationship for the decay rise ratio
across 27 different donors and as you
can see in each case the at higher
concentrations there's an increase in
this decay rise ratio that is
characteristic of QT prolongation or
delayed action potential and that the
model is able to fit each of those very
well within the range that there's no
data available so all 10 of the positive
control drugs exhibited this increase in
decay rise ratio across multiple donors
and as well at the highest
situations there's often the knotch
formation that I mentioned previously
for the three negative control drugs
some other donors did actually exhibit
an increase in the K rise ratio but none
of them let had that not CH formation
indicate indicative of us more serious
severe arrhythmia so our first
conclusion then with respect to hazard
you know we do seem to are able to
predict that QT prolongation will occur
for the positive drugs the question then
is quantitatively do we have that you
know is the relationship actually
accurate quantitatively now I should
note that even for this sort of
qualitative results the known positive
compounds had predicted effects when you
look only within the range of seen up to
the CM X of between 1 and 46% at this at
the c-max whereas the no negative
compounds if you only go up to cm x the
predicted effects were less than 1%
usually much less than 1% this suggests
that you know the negative compounds for
which we saw increases in the decay rise
ratio
those were concentrations that were
beyond the clinical doses and so it's
you know within the range in which
people are actually exposed that they
seem to be consistent so quantitatively
we can also make this comparison you
know graphically here where in each case
here on the left for again for dicey
pyramide this is the predicted
concentration response relationship for
you know as a function of free
consultation the percent change compared
in in vitro which is the colored shaded
regions for the confidence intervals and
then in vivo which are which are the
purple and black lines and as you can
see they lie right on top of each other
which is really a stunning result that
with no additional sort of fudge factors
or any type of calibration just using
from first principles free concentration
percent change and this cardiomyocyte
model were able to have very anchor
prediction of the invivo response
similarly on the right on the net for a
negative control again for the invivo
black line it only goes up to the C max
so within that range even though it's
the highest concentration there is some
effect in vitro within the range in
which is relevant clinically there is no
effect and the two results are
completely consistent so looking then
across all the different compounds over
on the left here is the population
median across our twenty seven
individuals for each of the compounds
for which there is a positive is a is a
known positive and as you can see the
know the grey line diagonal is no
exactly equal and then the dotted lines
are threefold up above or below now
almost all of our of our positive
controls are within a three fold within
three fold of the invivo result in terms
of this is the concentration at which
there's a 1% change in QT now one of the
reasons why we used a population of 27
individuals which is actually
coincidentally larger than you know some
of the clinical trial populations is
that we were concerned that if we just
use a single donor that there might be
that donor might be idiosyncratically
either more sensitive or more resistant
to these effects and indeed you know the
quote unquote standard donor that's sold
by CDI seems to be more sensitive than
the population median so if we would
only use a single cell line we would not
have had such you know such accurate
results as you can see here not only is
the scatter wider but also it tends to
be biased towards a higher a more
susceptible effect
so then in terms of clinical translation
we the this involves determining the
range of concentrations for which there
is a concern that is greater than 10
milliseconds change in QT and this is
shown on the graph on the left here and
so the range is that are below the
threshold of concern are shown by the
shaded regions at the bottom and then
the probability that the change in QT is
greater than 10 milliseconds is shown by
the by the curve lines and then the seam
axes are shown with the inverted
triangle and so as you can see all the
positive controls except for
moxifloxacin clearly fail the regulatory
safety threshold at the seam X and that
is of course as as is expected that is
that inverted triangle is above those
shaded regions that are at the bottom of
each graph and then the three negative
controls two of them except for
lamotrigine clearly satisfy the
regulatory threshold now interestingly
for the two that are more ambiguous
moxifloxacin only limit right gene these
have different conclusions at the
population level versus at the
individual level meaning no for any
individual random donor
it might not satisfy the regulatory
threshold even if for the no population
meeting and it does and this is actually
consistent with the clinical literature
in which these two compounds are a
little bit more ambiguous as to whether
they are quote unquote safe or not for
this endpoint so it appears central
offices is supported that we can predict
actually the concentration response
relationship and we can predict the
range of clinical concentrations that
satisfy the no typical regulatory
threshold so I'm going to end now with
some discussion of some implications in
future directions so first is that this
successful model really has six key
components that that were all needed in
order for it to accurately to make these
accurate
addictions first is that it used a
population of induced pluripotent stem
cells rather than a single donor and you
know as was shown in the earlier
scatterplot the single donor might be no
inaccurate in terms of comparing to in
vivo and vivo concentration response
relationships but taking the power of
the population you average out the
individual idiosyncrasies of individual
people second is that the decay rise
ratio appears to be an accurate
surrogate for the for clinic in vivo QT
and that no was not necessarily known to
be the case a lot of previous literature
really focused on that notch formation
rather than you know a continuous
measure such as that ratio between the
JK time and the rise time third is that
the Bayesian is the Bayesian population
modeling of concentration response it's
essentially a random effects model in
which you know there is a shrinkage for
a statistical shrinkage by using
multiple multiple donors allowing for a
confident a more confident estimate of
the population central tendency fourth
is the use of free concentration and
percent change to make that equivalence
between the in vivo and in vitro
concentration response relationships
since they are in different units using
different you know media forces theorem
and you know given the difference in
baseline beat rates with the between in
vivo and in vitro fifth is the
development of a clinical translation
model that in fact that then can
actually evaluate whether a compound
satisfies or does not satisfy a
particular regulatory safety threshold
and then sixth is something I haven't
talked about much but this experimental
protocol is suitable for high-throughput
screening we use 384 well plates in our
screening using calcium dye for to
measure the calcium flux and this is
much less onerous than some of the other
types of cardio toxicity in vitro
systems which involve actual electrical
measurements
of course there are a number of
limitations we only tested 13 drugs but
this really was limited by the
availability of published thorough QT
clinical data that included the
pharmacokinetic pharmacodynamic modeling
so that we could extract the
concentration response relationships
second it doesn't address some of the
more severe indicators of cardio
toxicity these are really early
biomarkers the QT is an early biomarker
of potential risk and so for those who
are interested in more severe effects
that we have not yet extended the model
to those and then third with 27
individuals we can't really describe
accurately the range of population
variability as in you know whether
there's there's an idiosyncratic
population there would need to be a
larger population to be assessed in this
model for for that to be the case but
the large the high-throughput screening
format using 384 well plates would
enable this type of work to be done
the vision then is a pure completely
predictive in vitro based model for
chemically induced cardiac arrhythmias
so starting with a DME on no there's a
lot of work on an on no firm sim sip and
say and such using in vitro and in
silico models for pharmacokinetics
and then the middle part using our vitro
model and vitro and silicone model for
the four MOCA dynamic portion to get to
QT prolongation and then at the tail end
there's a number of published
cardiovascular risk models that
incorporate that have started to
incorporate EKG measures such as QT in
there risk prediction and in some cases
they think these models claim to have
better prediction by including QT and
other types of EKG markers and so by
connecting these different models
together we would have a seamless
handoff from no exposure all the way
through population changes in in
population risk for cardiac arrhythmias
so the key messages I'd like you to take
away are these five bullets here first
is that a thorough QT studies are known
to be highly resource intensive even
though they are currently required for
regulatory safety the assessment of
drugs we asked here whether we could use
an in vitro population-based model
combined with in silico modeling to
actually predict what these thorough QT
studies these clinical trials that
actually measure and and also to go
beyond just you know sort of academic
interest but to actually have an output
that could be used in a regulatory
setting as to the presence or absence of
regulatory safety concerns
we found that for ten positive and three
negative control drugs we were able to
accurately predict vivo concentration QT
relationships as well as accurately
predict the presence or absence of
regulatory concern and so for
pharmaceuticals this thorough QT and a
dish type model could potentially reduce
the need for clinical thorough QT
studies in the future from and then I
think you know one of the large
you know unknowns here is for non non
pharmaceuticals
since there's so little known about the
potential cardiotoxicity
of environmental chemicals and here you
know the high-throughput format of this
thorough QT study in a dish can really
fill a critical gap in terms of
understanding both the hazard and
concentration response relationship for
chemicals to which we are all being
exposed and with that I thank you for
your time and attention and thank you
dr. Chiu for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
elaborate for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May 2019 as a final reminder dr.
Chiu will follow up with any questions
you submitted via email that's all for
now and thanks for joining us we'll see
you next time bye bye